[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم ال سي ابي
عاصي في الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى البدايه من تل ابيب نتابع
هذه الصور المباشره لاستمرار الاحتجاجات
في اسرائيل ضد تعديلات القضائيه
والى هذه الصور المباشره من مبنى الامم
المتحده بعد جلسه مفتوحه لمجلس الامن بشان
الذكاء الاصطناعي حتى خلالها الامين العام
للامم المتحده على التعامل مع التكنولوجيا
باحساس بالالحاح ونظره عالميه وعقليه
المتعلم كما قال
وهذه الصور من العاصمه اليونانيه اثينا
اتابع الصور المباشره مع اتساع حرائق
الغابات واجلاء سكان من بلدات المحيطه
باثنه وتحذيرا من اندلاع حرائق اضافيه مع
ارتفاع درجات الحراره
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
على خلفيه ازمه التعديلات القضائيه
احتجاجات في اسرائيل مع اقتراب تصويت
الكنيست على مشروع القانون المثير للجدل
اشتباكات بين الشرطه والمتظاهرين في مواقع
عده ونتنياهو يدافع عن التعديلات ويقول ان
حكومته تسعى لاستعاده التوازن بين السلطات
المعارك تحتدم في مدن العاصمه السودانيه
الثلاث طائرات الجيش السوداني تقصف مواقع
لقوات الدعم السريع وسط قصف المدفعي
واشتباكات في وسط ام درمان وجنوبها ونائبه
الامين العام للامم المتحده تطالب في
تصريحات للجزيره باقامه ممرات انسانيه
امنه للسودانيين وتقول ان كل الضالعين في
الصراع يجب ان يحاسبوا
وسط تصيد على جبهات القتال اوكرانيا تصف
الوضع الميداني في الشرق بالمعقد وروسيا
تقول ان قواتها تقدمت في اتجاه مدينه
كوفيانس في الشمال الشرقي ورئيس هيئه
الاركان الامريكيه يقول ان الهجوم
الاوكراني المضاد صعب وبطيء وتكلفته عاليه
في اطار جوله خليجيه هي الاولى منذ اعاده
انتخابه رئيسا اردوغان يعقد قمه مع امير
دوله قطر في الدوحه التي وصلها قادما من
جده الرئيس التركي وولي العهد السعودي
يشهدان توقيع تسعه اتفاقيات تعاون تشمل
مذكره تفاهم في مجال الدفاع لشراء
المسيرات التركيه وتعزيز القدرات الدفاعيه
السعوديه
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا تلقي الرئيس الامريكي
السابق دونالد ترامب رساله من المستشار
الخاص
تفيد بانه هدف في تحقيق لهيئه محلفين بشان
احداث اقتحام الكونجرس في السادس من يناير
وعلقت ترامب في بيان نشره عبر منصه على
هذه الخطوه بالقول هذه مطارده هو تسييس
وتدخل بالانتخابات لاستطاع ارائكم بشان
هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال
التالي برايكم في اي سياق تاتي الرساله
التي تلقاها ترامب من المدعي العام المكلف
بقضيه اقتحام الكونجرس 60% قالوا انها
متابعه لقضايا ومخالفات قانونيه يتهم فيها
ترامب و40% اعتبروها ملاحقه سياسيه للرئيس
السابق قبل الانتخابات
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده
ومتفاعله عربيا ودوليا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
خلال جلسه لمجلس الامن الدولي تحذير اممي
من التفاعل بين الذكاء الاصطناعي والاسلحه
النوويه
[موسيقى]
في اسرائيل تتواصل الاحتجاجات الشعبيه ضد
سعي حكومه بنيامين نتنياهو لتمرير جمله من
التشريعات يعتبرها المحتجون انقلابا على
الشرعيه وعلى ديمقراطيه وقد تظاهر عشرات
الالاف من الاسرائيليين في مناطق مختلفه
محاولين شل حركه الطرقات وسير القطارات في
محطات مركزيه ياتي هذا في وقت يواصل فيه
الكنيست مناقشه تعديل قانوني يرمي الى
تقليص صلاحيات قضاه المحكمه العليا ومنعهم
من الغاء اي قرارات او تعيينات من طرف
الحكومه
تركوا اعمالهم واشغالهم وبيوتهم وخرجوا
للتو
يقولون انهم يدافعون عن الديمقراطيه في
اسرائيل في وجه ما يسمونه انقلابا على
نظام الحكم فيها من قبل حكومه اليمين
المتطرف
بدون رقابه قضائيه الحكومه تتحول الى
ديكتاتوريه وبامكانها فعل اي شيء ونحن لن
نسمح بذلك
نتنياهو فاسد ومحرض ويخلق حربا اهليه
مكانه الوحيد السجن نتنياهو هو اكبر خطر
على اسرائيل
الاحتجاجات شلت شوارع الرئيسيه في اسرائيل
ولم تخلو من عنف واعتقالات من قبل الشرطه
التي حجزت قواتها باعداد كبيره للتصدي لها
لكن الدعوات لعصيان الاوامر العسكريه من
قبل ضباط وجنود في وحدات النخبه في الجيش
الاسرائيلي كان لها وقع اخر يقول هؤلاء
انهم لن يخدموا تحت حكومه ديكتاتوريه ولا
يستبعدون تعرضهم لدعاوى في محكمه الجنايات
الدوليه
عند انتخاب القضاه من قبل السياسيين فان
جهاز القضائي الاسرائيلي سيفقد مصداقيته
في المجتمع الدولي وعليه ثمه مخاوف لدى
جنود الاحتياط والطيارين من ان ترفع ضدهم
دعاوى خارج البلاد ثم قلقم في اوساط
سياسيه وعسكريه من ظاهره عصيان الاوامر
العسكريه ترى انها تمس ابناء اسرائيل
وتشجع اعدائها على مهاجمتها
الامنيه الحاليه تلزمنا بان نكون على
جاهزيه عاليه ومن يدعو الى عدم الخدمه
العسكريه في هذه الايام يمس بالجيش
الاسرائيلي وبامن الدوله
معظم شرائح المجتمع في اسرائيل انضمت الى
هذه الاحتجاجات اضطر ان تقليص صلاحيات
المحكمه العليا وتكبيل ايدي قضاتها
سيركزان في يد الحكومه الاسرائيليه
صلاحيات مطلقه وسيحسنها في وجه اي رقابه
قضائيه
لم تشهد اسرائيل منذ تاسيسها لهذه
الاحتجاجات الشعبيه المتواصله كما لم تعيش
حاله انقسام وشقاق كهذه حاله فما ثمن يذهب
الى حد تشبيهها بالاسباب التي ادت الى
انهيار ممالك اسرائيل وهياكل
الجزيره تل ابي
كما تتصاعد في اسرائيل دعوات الى عدم
الالتحاق بالجيش والخدمه الاحتياطيه
الالزاميه ورغم العقوبات المفروضه بموجب
القانون الاسرائيلي على مثل هذه الدعوات
فان هذا الاتجاه يقوده ضابط ضباط عفوا
وجنود متطوعون خدم سابقا في الجيش
الاسرائيلي
[موسيقى]
بالتوازي مع الاحتياجات في شوارع المدن
الاسرائيليه الرافضه لخطه التغييرات
القضائيه تنطلق نداءات تدعو الى التخلف عن
الالتحاق بالخدمه او الاحتياط الالزامي من
ضباط وطيارين وجنود واطباء ومسعفين وغيرهم
عام 2016 اقر الكنيست قانونا يقضي بالحبس
سبعه اعوام لمن يحرض ضد التجنيد في الجيش
الاسرائيلي اما رافض والتجنيد الاجباريه
والاحتياط الالزامي فيتعرضون لمحاكمات
عسكريه وقد يحكم عليهم بالسجن من خمسه
ايام حتى 30 يوما قابله للتمديد بما يصل
مده الحبس الى كامل مده الخدمه العسكريه
اي ثلاثه اعوام تقريبا
التخلف عن الخدمه بالجيش الاسرائيلي ليست
حدثا جديدا وتصفه السلطات الاسرائيليه
سابقا بالمحدود اكثر اسبابهم ما يطلق عليه
برفض الخدمه بدافع الضمير انطلاقا من رفض
العنف او بحمل السلاح او رفض سياسه الفصل
العنصري كما تحدثت وسائل اعلام عن تعرض
[__] الخدمه بالجيش الاسرائيلي بدوافع
سياسيه لمضايقات ومعامله سيئه خلال فتره
حبسهما المتكرره لا توجد ارقام دقيقه حتى
الان بشان عدد من رفضوا الالتحاق بالتجنيد
المؤشر الاكثر وضوحا كان تصريحات
المسؤولين الاسرائيليين ومنهم وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي يواف جراند وصف جالنت الدعوات
المتصاعده لرفض الخدمه العسكريه بانها
تهدد وحده الصف وتمثل جائزه لاعداء
اسرائيل
من تل ابيب ينضم الينا مايكل كلاينر رئيس
المحكمه العليا لحزب الليكود وعضو الكنيسه
السابق عن الحزب سيد مايكل كلاينر يقول
احد المتظاهرين اليوم في تل ابيب كلما
ضغطتم في يعني في حديثه الى المؤيدين
للتعديلات على صلاحيات المحكمه العليا
كلما ضغطتم للتمرير هذه التعديلات ستزداد
حجم مظاهراتنا لاننا لن نقبل
بالديكتاتوريه كيف ترد على هذا الكلام
في البدايه نحن نتحدث عن هذا الخطاب وهذا
الشعار الذي يقول ان اسرائيل تود ان تتحول
الى ديكتاتوريه ولكننا نقوم بحمايه الشعب
من خلال الكنيستو والكنيست هو الجهل
مسؤوله عن التشريعات والائتلاف هو الذي
كسب في الانتخابات ان الاقليه التي خسرت
في الانتخابات تحاول ان تمنع الكنيسه من
ان يؤدي الدوره التشريعي هو الفعل غير
الديمقراطي وهو يخرق كل القوانين
الديمقراطيه في العالم والحكومه لن تقبل
ويجب ان لا تقبل بل رضوخي لهذا الضغط غير
القانوني الاقليه تضغط على الحكومه وتحاول
ان تمنع المشرعين من القيام بعملهم
انت
تقول حقيقه شرائح واسعه من المواطنين
رفضوا هذه التعديلات ويرفضون هذه
التعديلات وبدا هذا الرفض ايضا يتسرب الى
الجيش
في الحقيقه هناك عدد كبير من الناس الذين
صوتوا واقترعوا وطبعا هناك مظاهرات في
الوقت نفسه نعم هذه المظاهرات مكفوله هو
هي حقا دوستوري وطبعا هذه كلها امور
مقبوله ولكن بالنسبه الى الناس الذين هم
في الجيش اذا ما قالوا ان هذا الامر غير
مقبول من قبلهم ولن يقبلوا الاوامر هذا
امر هذا امر غير مقبول وهناك دائما اقليه
واكثريه في نظام الديمقراطي هذه التهديدات
غير قانونيه وغير شرعيه وحتى لو كان هناك
حاجه للقيام ببعض التنازلات من خلال
التهديد هذا لن يؤدي الى الحل لانه اذا ما
رضخت الحكومه للتهديدات هذا يعني ان
الاقليه يمكنها ان تحكم الاكثريه لا
تستطيع انها ردخت في السابق واجلت البحث
في هذه التعديلات بعدما حدث في الشارع
واليوم حتى المجتمع الدولي يضغط الولايات
المتحده تقول في بيان للبيت الابيض انه لا
يجب تمرير هذه التعديلات من دون وجود
اجماع حولها
نحن نتحدث عن سلوكا غير قانوني اخر غير
شرعي اخر الاستعمال هذا استعمال الدول
الاجنبيه من اجل الضغط على اسرائيل بهذه
الطريقه هو امر غير قانوني ان محاوله
التدخل بهذه الطريقه هي محاوله غير شرعيه
الطريق الوحيده هي الطريق الديمقراطيه
هؤلاء الذين يتظاهرون ويعارضون بالاضافه
الى القضاه يمكنهم ان يترشحوا في
الانتخابات المقبله واذا ما حصلوا على
الاكثريه يمكنهم ان يغيروا التشريعات
ويوقف التعديلات ويسن تشريعات جديده
عضو الكنيست السابق عن الحزب من تل ابيب
مباشره الى هذه الصور التي تريدنا من تل
ابيب لاستمرار التظاهرات وكما ذكرنا هذه
التظاهرات كانت عمت مناطق ومدن اسرائيليه
عده اليوم رفضا
لسعي حكومه بنيامين نتنياهو لتمرير جمله
من التشريعات
يعتبرها المحتاجون انقلابا على الشرعيه
والديمقراطيه على راس هذه التعديلات ما
يتصل
بصلاحيات المحكمه العليا يمس هذه
الصلاحيات ويعتبر المتظاهرون انها تقلص من
استقلاليه هذه المحكمه العليا لانها
تخضعها
للحكومه والسياسيين
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
طبعا هذا الاسبوع الثامن والعشرين التي
تتواصل فيها هذا التظاهرات في تل ابيب
وحول هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا عكيفه الدار
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي الاسرائيلي من تل
ابيب سيد عكيفه الدار 28 اسبوعا من
التظاهر ضد التشريعات وهذه التعديلات التي
تمس المحكمه العليا ولكن ماذا حققت هذه
التظاهرات والحكومه والكنيست يبدو انه ذهب
للتصويت عليها وتمريرها
في الحقيقه
المساله الاساسيه التي يجب ان نتحدث عنها
هي تنتظرنا في واشنطن رئيس الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه التقى بالرئيس
الاسرائيلي وكان هناك رساله موجهه لرئيس
مجلس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو
ويتعين على نتنياهو ان يقرر الان ما هي
الاولويات بالنسبه اليه بالنسبه الى
الموقف في المجتمع
الاسرائيلي يظهر بالاضافه الى مصلحه
اسرائيل الاستراتيجيه الا وهي التحالف
الاستراتيجي مع الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ويوم غد سوف يخاطب
الكونجرس الامريكي ونستمع بالتالي الى
موقفه لانه والى حد علمي هو شخصيا لديه
قلق بالغ وعميق ازاء اتجاهات هذه الحكومه
غير
الديمقراطيه وبعض الناس يتحدثون عن نظام
الديكتاتوري اذا سيد
فرض الان والذين يعارضون هذه التعديلات
يراهنون على موقف الولايات المتحده كما
افهم منك ولكن قبل قليل كان معنا السيد
مايكل كلاينر من حزب الليكود ويقول ان هذا
امر غير شرعي غير قانوني وهذا تدخل في
شؤون داخليه اسرائيليه وانقلاب على نتيجه
الانتخابات
اذا بالنسبه الى ما قاله السيد
كلاينر اذا ما كان
لا يزال يستمع انا يسعدني ان اذكره واذكر
المشاهدين انه منذ سنوات رئيس مجلس
الوزراء نتنياهو خاطب
الكونغرس الامريكي من دون علمي او من دون
ترتيبا من رئيس الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه قام بترتيب اجتماعات ادت الى
اقناع الكونغرس الامريكي وطبعا بعد ذلك
الرئيس الامريكي انذاك دونالد ترامب انسحب
من
اتفاق النووي مع ايران خطه العمل الشامله
المشتركه وبالتالي هذه المجموعه هي اخر
مجموعه يمكنها
تلقي المحاضرات امام المجتمع الاسرائيلي
بالنسبه الى هذه المواطن ماذا ماذا بقي
عويل
في الامريكي بعد الاتصال الذي جرى بين
بيضا ونتنياهو والحديث عن اتفاق على لقاء
بينهما في الولايات المتحده خاصه في هذا
التوقيت قبيل الذهاب نحو التصويت على هذه
التعديلات هل مازال بالامكان التعويل على
هذا الموقف الامريكي
اعتقد ان
القوه الوحيده في العالم التي باستطاعتها
ان تقنع الرئيس رئيس
الولايات المتحده
ويمكننا ان نعطيه بعض
الاحتمالات المرتبطه بمستقبله الشخصي
لانني اود ان اذكر المشاهدين الكرام في
الوقت نفسه ان
نتنياهو يقترب من حكما بالفساد من قبل
المحاكم الاسرائيليه بقضيه فساد يمكن ان
تؤدي به الى السجن وبالتالي اذا ما كان
نتنياهو لديه اي اهتمام بمستقبل اسرائيل
خصوصا بعد موقف الطيارين الاسرائيليين على
سبيل المثال اليوم 100 طيار قالوا لن
يخدموا تحت دكتاتوريه وبالتالي اذا ما كان
اود السيد نتنياهو ان يصغي الى تصريحات
بعض الوزراء في حكوماتها الذين صرحوا ضد
هذه الخطوات المجنونه غير الديمقراطيه
التي
تخطيها
الحكومه والائتلاف يجب ان يفهم نتنياهو
اهميه العلاقه بين الكاتب والمحلل السياسي
الاسرائيلي من تل ابيب
[موسيقى]
الى السودان حيث تحتدم المعارك في مدن
العاصمه السودانيه الثلاث فقد افاد مراسل
الجزيره بان طائرات حربيه تابعه للجيش
استهدفت مواقع لقوات الدعم السريع في
الخرطوم بحري وحاولت المضادات الارضيه
التابعه لقوات الدعم السريع التصدي لها في
اجواء مناطق مختلفه من العاصمه وفي ام
درمان تجدد القصف المدفعي في عده مواقع
بينما اندلعت اشتباكات متقطعه في وسط
المدينه وجنوبها
من جهتها اعربت بعثه الامم المتحده لدعم
المرحله الانتقاليه في السودان عن قلقها
ازاء القتال الذي يدور بين الجيش السوداني
والحركه الشعبيه لتحرير السودان بزعامه
عبد العزيز الحلو في ولايه جنوب كردفان
وحثت البعثه في تعميم صحفي طرفي القتال
على وقف العمليات العسكريه فورا من اجل
تهدئه الوضع واستئناف المفاوضات ومنع
توسيع الصراع وذكر البيان ذكر جميع
الاطراف بالتزاماتها بموجب القانون الدولي
الانساني والقانون الدولي لحقوق الانسان
بضمان سلامه جميع المدنيين من جهه قال
المتحدث باسم الامين العام للامم المتحده
ان ارقام المنظمه الدوليه للهجره تؤكد
نزوح مليونين و600 الف شخص داخل السودان
منذ بدايه الصراع في حين بلغ عدد من عبر
الحدود الى دول الجوار 730 الف شخص
[موسيقى]
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه احباط محاوله
هجوم اوكرانيه جديده وصفتها بالارهابيه
باستخدام طائرات مسيره على اهداف في شبه
جزيره القرم وقالت الوزاره في بيان ان
دفاعاتها الجويه اعترضت الليله الماضيه
سبعه عشره مسيره واسقطت احدى عشره مسيره
اخرى باستخدام وسائل الحرب الالكترونيه
دون وقوع خسائر وفق الوزاره وكانت القوات
الاوكرانيه قالت امس انها استهدفت جسر
القرم الاستراتيجي بزورقين مسيرين
قال المتحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان
القوات الروسيه شنت هجمات صاروخيه عاليه
الدقه وصفها
بالانتقاميه على منشات اوكرانيه لتصنيع
قوارب مسيره في منطقه اوديسا اضاف ان هذه
المسيرات كانت تستعد لشن هجمات وصفها
بالارهابيه على روسيا
نفذت القوات المسلحه الروسيه خلال الليل
ضربه شامله انتقاميه باسلحه بحريه عاليه
الدقه على منشاه يتم فيها التحضير لاعمال
ارهابيه ضد روسيا باستخدام قوارب مسيره
وايضا على مواقع لصناعه تلك القوارب في
حوض لبناء السفن بالقرب من مدينه اوديسا
بالاضافه الى ذلك تم تدمير مستودعات
لتخزين الوقود في مقاطاعتين
تبلغ ساعتها نحو 70 الف طن تم منها تزويد
المعدات العسكريه الاوكرانيه بالوقود
من جانبها قالت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه
ان القوات الروسيه اطلقت خمسه صواريخ اس
360 صاروخا من انواع مختلفه كما قالت
وسائل اعلام روسيه ان القوات الروسيه شنت
هجوما صاروخيا وصفته بالكبير على مدن
اوديسا وميكوليف وخاركيز الاوكرانيه ونشرت
صورا قالت انها للهجوم الصاروخي الذي شنته
القوات الروسيه على المدن الاوكرانيه
الثلاث كما اعلنت تفعيل منظومه الدفاع
الجوي في المنطقه
تفاصيل المشهد نتابعها في التقرير التالي
نحو عام ونصف على الحرب الروسيه في
اوكرانيا تعكس الجبهه الصوره الاكثر دقه
للصراع هناك نزاع استراتيجي على منطقه
تحتاج اليها روسيا بشده ولا يمكن
لاوكرانيا في السياسه والامن ان تتخلى
عنها منطقه البحر الاسود وشبه جزيره القرم
والمنافذ اليهما
تلقت موسكو ضربه باستهداف جسر القرم في
عمليه النوعيه هي الثانيه في اقل من عام
واحد الامر الذي تعده روسيا تهديدا
استراتيجيا وحيويا لا يمكنها التهاون
ازائه الضغط الاوكراني على القرمستمر وفي
الليله عينها تعرضت مدينه سيفاستوب لهجمات
مكثفه بنحو 30 طائره اوكرانيه مسيره وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه قالت ان دفاعاتها الجويه
اعترضت سبعه عشره منها واكدت ان وحداتها
اسقطت احدى عشره مسيره اخرى باستخدام
وسائل الحرب الالكترونيه
ولشبه جزيره القرم اهميه جيوسياسيه عاليه
فهي ممر روسيا على المياه الدافئه الى
البحر الاسود
ومنفذها باتجاه مضيقي البوسفور والدردنيل
وصولا الى البحر المتوسط
وتعتبر مدينه سيفاستوبل مقر قياده اسطول
البحر الاسود الروسي وسيطره موسكو على شبه
الجزيره تسمح للصواريخ الروسيه بتغطيه
الجزء الشرقي من اوروبا كاملا الرد الروسي
كان مزدوجا بالرسائل عسكريه انتقاميه ردا
على ضربه جسر القرم وكذلك حمل دلاله
تحذيريه
فالجيش شن هجمات صاروخيه عاليه الدقه على
منشات اوكرانيه قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
انها لتصنيع قوارب مسيره في اوديسا كما
استهدف القصف ميكلايف وكلاهما على البحر
الاسود
وتعتبران منطلقا للسفن التي تنقل الحبوب
الاوكرانيه ضمن اتفاق البحر الاسود
فالسلطات الروسيه تحذر من انها لن تستطيع
الحفاظ على امن ممرات الحبوب بعدما انسحبت
من الاتفاقيه وتتهم كييف باستخدام اتفاقيه
الحبوب لاغراض عسكريه
[موسيقى]
حول هذا الموضوع ينضم
اليناك كمساعد وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
السابق ومعنى من موسكو الكسندر ارتامونوف
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي مرحبا بكما
سيد اليكساندر ارتامونوف سنبدا معك ماذا
حققت روسيا من وراء استهداف الجنوب والشرق
اليوم ردا على مقاله انه استهداف لجسر
القرم وتحديدا هنا اسالك عن اوديسا ماذا
تحقق من استهداف اوديسا
لدى روسيا
استراتيجيه محدده هذه الاستراتيجيه تعتمد
على رده الفعل هذا يعني انه اذا هناك اي
سلاح يثير
عريضه الجيش الروسي اذا يجب ان يكون هناك
ضربات ضده او على
مصادر لهذا الازعاج
او لمستودعات
الذخيره بعد الهجمات على جسر القرم
استخدمت مسيرات مائيه هي قوارب قد تكون
امريكيه اوكرانيه لذلك حسب علمي كان هناك
قرار ان تدمر جميع مصانع هذه المعدات في
خرسون وفي نيكولاي وفي اوديسا هذا بالطبع
حسب ما استطعنا ان نقوم به
باختراق انظمه الدفاع الجويه الاوكرانيه
حول المناطق اما حسب ما علمت دمر مخزن
للذخيره وايضا
مستودع للوقود ومن الذخيره كان هناك
قد تكون هذه المعلومات اوكرانيا سريه ولكن
حسب معلوماتنا دمر مستودع
لقوارب المسيره التي كانت قد استخدمت فيها
هجمات ضد السفن الروسيه في ازوف وفيخرس
طيب سيد سيد اوليكسيه منك اليوم يعني بعد
الضربه التي
جرت على جسر القرم اليوم السلطات الروسيه
اعلنت اعاده تسير الجسر بشكل جزئي وقامت
بضرب هذه المنشات لتصنيع القوارب المسيره
في اوديسا وبالتالي لو نظرنا الى مقامت
بها سلطات الاوكرانيه من استهداف للجسر
الان في ضوء
ما استتبعه هذا الاستهداف كيف يمكن تقييم
هذه العمليه العسكريه
حسب معلوماتي
الهجمات كانت على مواقع ليس لها اي صله
بالمواقع العسكريه الحديث هنا عن
الموانئ التي كانت تستخدم عن نقل الحبوب
وكان هذا في الوقت الذي تخرج فيه روسيا من
اتفاقيه الحبوب وقامت بهجمات على الاماكن
التي كانت تحمل فيها الحبوب لنقلها لاسيا
وافريقيا ما كنت
اصل بين الهجمات على
الجسر وهجمات روسيا على المدن
الاوكرانيه لان روسيا
تحاول طول الوقت ان تبرر هجماتها وكانها
ردا على اعمال اوكرانيه ولكن تذكرنا شهر
مايو عندما قاموا بضربه كييف وكان هذا
يتكرر ليليا بالصواريخ
ولم يكن هناك اي اسباب اوكرانيه لهذه
الهجمات لذلك الروس
يقوم باعمال ويظهر انهم مضطرين للرد على
الاعمال الاوكرانيه التي في الواقع تقع في
اطار الدفاع عن النفس من قبل اوكرانيا
هل يمكن الحديث عن رد فعل روسي ان كانت
روسيا هي من يقوم بفعل الغزو لاوكرانيا
وبالتالي هذا يعطي اوكرانيا مشروعيه
القيام بعمل بعمليات ضد المعتدي
هذا السؤال كيف تقول الهجمات ضد اوكرانيا
ان روسيا تقوم بعمليه عسكريه خاصه وهي
بدات من العام الماضي وبدات بعدما قامت
اوكرانيا بهجم
الدمباسكي في عام 2014 بعد ما رفضت
اوكرانيا انفصال هذه المناطق ومن الممكن
ان تاتي وتزوري هذه المناطق لتري اثار هذه
الضرابات ما تقوم به اوكرانيا هي تظهر
انها تستطيع ان تقوم باي شيء باستخدام
الاسلحه الموجوده لديها بما فيها هجمات
على الاراضي والمناطق الروسيه على موسكو
كما تعلمين انه في قطاع موسكو وفي المناطق
التي تتواجد فيها منشاه ذريه مثل بوشاتف
حيث المحطه الذريه لذلك لا اعتقد
ان روسيا ان اوكرانيا عفوا تقف عند اي
حدود بل روسيا هي من تمتنع عن استخدام
الاسلحه المتواجده منها ممكن ان نستخدم
الصواريخ التي تخترق الخنادق المسلحه
واذكر ان
التسجيل
اوليكس الم تضعف الحجه الاوكرانيه التي
تحدثت عنها قبل قليل وقلت ان اوكرانيا
تقوم برد الهجمات عندما بدات اوكرانيا
بهجوم على الاراضي الروسيه عندما بدا
المسؤولون العسكريون الاوكرانيون يتحدثون
عن نقل المعركه الى داخل روسيا عند اللجوء
الى استخدام اسلحه محرمه هي القنابل
العنقوديه
فعلا
لدينا
فهم
متضارب بالنسبه
لفهم اساس النزاع الاوكراني الروسي روسيا
بدات
باعتداء دون اي سبب ضد دوله لها سيادتها
واوكرانيا لديها حق كامل ان تدافع عن
انفسها اعتمادا على القانون رقم 51 في
قوانين الامم المتحده
وهذا يعني
وهذا يشمل استخدام اي اي من الوسائل
المتاحه للقيام بضربات ليس على اراضي
العدو فقط وليس على اراضي المحتله فقط من
الممكن الهجوم على اي اهداف مشروعه على
الاراضي الروسيه والاراضي الروسيه هي هدف
من هذه الاهداف والجسر ايضا لانه يستخدم
لنقل سبعين بالمئه من الذخيره المستخدمه
في دعم المجموعه المسلحه الروسيه مساعد
وزير الدفاع الاوكرانيه السابق وشكرا
للسيد الكسندر ارتامونوف الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي من موسكو
[موسيقى]
دعت الامينه العامه للامم المتحده امينه
محمد في حديث خاص للجزيره الى محاسبه جميع
اطراف النزاع في السودان وشددت المسؤوله
الامميه على ضروره انهاء الحرب الدائره
هناك وعدم الاكتفاء باحصاء الفظائع حسب
تعبيرها
محاسبه جميع اطراف النزاع لا يمكن السماح
بتجاوز هذا الموضوع يجب ان تكون هناك
محاسبه ولكن علينا ان نضع حدا لتلك
الفضائع لا احصائها فحسب يجب ان ننهي
الحرب ويجب ان نعتني بالمدنيين الذين
يفرون وعلينا تحقيق هذين الامرين معا
[موسيقى]
استقبل امير دوله قطر الشيخ تميم بن حمد
اللساني في قصر لوسيل الرئيس التركي رجب
طيب اردوغان الذي يزور الدوحه في اطار
جولتها الخليجيه وعقد الزعيمان قمه ثنائيه
تناولت عددا من الملفات المهمه تصدرتها
العلاقات الثنائيه وشراكه الاستراتيجيه
بين البلدين
بالتزامن مع الذكرى الخمسين لتاسيس
العلاقات الدبلوماسيه بين البلدين انعقدت
القمه القطريه التركيه بحض تدمير دوله قطر
شيخ تميم بن حمد ال ثاني والرئيس التركي
رجب طيب اردوغان لتؤكد على عمق الشراكه
الاستراتيجيه بين الجانبين وتفتح افاقا
جديده للتعاون في ظل التطورات الراهنه
والمتسارعه اقليميا ودوليا وناقشت القمه
تعزيز العلاقات الثنائيه والخطوات التي
يجب اتخاذها بما يخدم المصالح المشتركه
والاستقرار في المنطقه وهو ما تتابعه
اللجنه العليا المشتركه القطريه التركيه
في كافه المجالات وابرزها الملفات
المتعلقه بالاقتصاد والاستثمار والطاقه
وصناعات الدفاعيه وحتى السياحه ومشاريع
البنى التحتيه لسيما وان قطر تعد احد اكبر
المستثمرين في تركيا حيث تجاوز حجم
التبادل التجاري بين البلدين ملياريين
دولار العام الماضي والمامول من اللقاء
القطري التركي هو استدامه الشراكه
الاستراتيجيه لتحقيق مصالح البلدين
المشتركه
سار رشيد الجزيره الدوحه
اعرب امير دوله قطر الشيخ تميم بن حمد
اللساني عن سعادته باستضافه الرئيس التركي
رجب طيب اردوغان في الدوحه وقال امير قطر
في تغريده ان اللقاء ياتي في اطار رفض
التعاون الاقتصادي بين البلدين بمزيد من
الفرص والافاق الواعده وبما يحقق المصالح
المشتركه للشعبين الشقيقين اضاف امير قطر
انه ناقش كذلك مع الضيف التركي مختلف
التحديات التي تواجهها المنطقه والعالم
واكدا اهميه تعزيز التكاتف الدولي للتصدي
له
وكان ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن
سلمان قد بحث مع الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان في مدينه جده تعزيز العلاقات
الثنائيه بين البلدين والقضايا ذات
الاهتمام المشترك وسبق هذه الزياره تنظيم
منتدى الاعمال السعودي التركي في جده حيث
تم التوقيع على تسع اتفاقيات بين الجانبين
وجار بحث العديد من المجالات منها الطاقه
والسياحه ومشاريع البنى التحتيه
سعيا الى تعزيز فرص التعاون السياسي
والاقتصادي بين السعوديه وتركيا يزور
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان مدينه جده
مفتتحا بها جولته الخليجيه التي ستشمل قطر
والامارات
وعقد جلسه مباحثات تناولت ملفات اقليميه
ودوليه تم التوقيع على عدد من الاتفاقيات
بين البلدين شملت مختلفه مجالات التعاون
في الصناعه والتجاره وغيرهما منذ زياره
ولي العهد لتركيا في يونيو 2022 تلبيه
لدعوه الرئيس التركي ونحن نشهد عزمه قاده
البلدين لتعزيز العلاقات الثنائيه الاخويه
لخدمه المصالح المشتركه بين البلدين
ونقلها لمستويات غير مسبوقه حقيقه ما
يجمعنا مع تركيا الكثير يجمعنا التاريخ
والعقيده والدين وعلاقه دبلوماسيه ممتده
مع تركيا الدوله من العام 1929 وقد قدم
الرئيس اردوغان سياره كهربائيه تركيه تحمل
اسم تونغ انتجت في اكتوبر 2022
هديه لولي العهد الامير محمد بن سلمان
زياره الرئيس التركي للسعوديه سبقها تنظيم
المنتدى السعودي التركي حيث وقعت 9
اتفاقيات شملت قطاعات مختلفه من الصناعات
الدفاعيه والطاقه والسياحه ومشاريع البلاد
تحتيه على مستوى القطاع الخاص السعودي لمس
الاهتمام الكبير من الشركات التركيه
للدخول في سوق المملكه والاستثمار فيها
رؤيه المملكه 2030 ودعم سمو الامير محمد
بن سلمان لكل مواضيع المتعلقه بالاستثمار
غيرت الكثير من المفاهيم لدى المستثمرين
الدوليين وجعلت المملكه ولله الحمد ووجهها
استثماريه مغريه واعلن وزير الدفاع
السعودي الامير خالد بن سلمان توقيع عقدين
بين وزاره الدفاع السعوديه وشركه باي كارا
تركيه للصناعات الدفاعيه بشان طائرات
مسيره
وهم اعتبره الجانب التركي اكبر صفقه تصدير
في مجال الدفاع والطيران في تاريخ
الجمهوريه التركيه
تعزيز التعاون الاقتصادي والدفاعي كان
العنوان الابرز في زياره الرئيس التركي
رجب طيب اردوغان الى السعوديه اولى محطاته
العربيه بعد اعاده انتخابه رئيسا وهما
سيعطي العلاقه بين انقره والرياض دفعه
نقوى في التكامل والشراكه بدر ربيعان
الجزيره
جده
ينضم الينا من الكويت الدكتور عبد الله
الشايجي استاذ العلوم السياسيه في جامعه
الكويت مرحبا بك دكتور ما اهميه هذه
الجوله التي يقوم بها الرئيس التركي في
دول الخليج
اهميه كبيره هذه الجوله يعني هي اول جوله
يقوم بها لعده دول منذ فوزه بالرئاسه
للفتره الثالثه والاخيره وهو وعد بانه
سيقوم بزياره للشكر الدول الخليج التي
وقفت معه خلال السنه الماضيه تقريبا وهذه
زياره يعني في تكرار على ما يبدو زياره
العام الماضي كانت للسعوديه وقطر زياره
ايضا مسؤولين سعوديين بما فيهم ولي العهد
السعودي العام الماضي السماح للسعوديين
بالسفر الى تركيا والاستثمارات في تركيا
قطر تبرز بانها اللاعب الرئيسي الان يعني
هناك استثمارات كبيره علاقه استراتيجيه
شراكه زياره الامارات ايضا نذكر بانه
رئيس دوله الامارات الشيخ محمد بن زايد
زارا شهر الماضي ايضا تركيا وانها الرئيس
وحضر مباراه بطوله كاس اوروبا وسي
ايضا اليوم مساء اليوم وغدا الامارات هناك
طبعا هي زياره سياسيه اقتصاديه استثماريه
لان وضع الاقتصاد التركي بحاجه الى ضخ
استثمارات شراكات وهذه الزياره تصب في ذلك
التوثيق العلاقه
دكتور عبد الله توثيق توثيق العلاقه
وتطبيع العلاقه وهذا التقارب وهذه
الاتفاقات التي يتم
توقيعها كل ذلك كيف من شانه ان ينعكس على
مختلف القضايا في المنطقه
يعني تركيا هي قوه اعتدال في المنطقات
تركيا تبرز بانها لاعب قد يلعب دور امني
دفاعي هناك توقيع اتفاقيات امنيه مع مع
قطر كما راينا في الازمه الخليجيه هناك
ايضا تنسيق امني ودفاعي مع الكويت الكويت
كانت من الاوائل الدول التي وقعت اتفاقيه
صفقه عسكريه في الشهر الماضي لشراء مسيرات
بيرقدار التي اثبتت نجاحها وفعاليتها في
الحروب الاخيره خاصه في اوكرانيا
واذربيجان السعوديه امس وقعت ايضا
اتفاقيه عسكريه لشراء مسيرات بيرقدار قطر
عندها ايضا اتفاقيه على ما يبدو بان هناك
مزيج من القوه الناعمه التركيه
الاستثمارات والشراكه الاقتصاديه والسياحه
والسفر والاستثمارات بالاضافه الى القوه
العسكريه الامنيه التي اثبتت لقطر ب تركيا
حليف موثوق ولهذا السبب هناك 30 قمه عقدت
بين امير قطر وبين الرئيس اردوغان هناك
ارتياح لفوز اردوغان في المنطقه رئيس مجرب
ورئيس يفهم ولديه يفهم يعني البعد المهم
للعلاقه الخليجيه التركيه وهذه الزياره هي
الاولى لها مغزى ايضا بزياره دول مجلس
التعاون الخليجي ثلاث دول نصف الدول
الخليجيه الان يزورها رئيس اردوغان ويفتح
المجال امام الاستثمارات وامام الشراكه
العسكريه اذكر هنا بانه هذا الشهر صدر قبل
ايام التقرير السنوي لفاير باور انديكس
لاقيس ترتيب القوات العسكريه في العالم
وتركيا تحتل المرتبه الاولى في الشرق
الاوسط متقدمه على اسرائيل وايران
والمرتبه 11 في العالم ولديها العام قدرات
صناعيه متطوره وهذا طبعا يمكن ان يلعب دور
في زياده وتعطيض الامن الخليجي عبر ايضا
تركيا على صعيد السياسي دكتور عبد الله
الان ما هي المصلحه المشتركه بين دول
الخليج وتركيا
المصلحه واضحه يعني فيما نسميه المعادله
رابح رابح يعني دول الخليج تنظر الى الى
العلاقه مع تركيا بان علاقه مهمه علاقه
محوريه تركيا لاعب مهم في الشرق الاوسط
تركي ايضا لاعب مهم على المستوى الدولي
راينا دور تركيا في النيتو وكيف انها
استخدمت الفيتو لمعارضه انضمام فنلندا
والسويد ثم تركيا تراجعت بمقابل مقايضه او
مقابل صفقه تركيا تلعب دور ايضا في
الوساطه بين بين روسيا وبين اوكرانيا
تعطل او او تجميد بوتين صفقه الحبوب التي
سيعاني منها الكثير في العالم
يعني كوننا حلفاء وثيقين مع تركيا بعدما
مرت به خلال عقد الماضي حرب بارده بين دول
الخليجيه وبين تركيا والان تمهد الطريق من
مقاطعه المنتجات التركيه الى تركيا حليف
استراتيجي وتركي حليف يمكن التعويل عليه
امنيا وعسكريا واقتصاديا واستثماريا وتركي
عندها ايضا مجالات واسعه جدا للاستثمار في
جميع
القطاعات الحيويه الموجوده في تركيا فهي
مصلحه مشتركه لكلا الطرفين خاصه الاقتصاد
التركي يعاني بشكل كبير من التضخم ومن
ارتفاع الفائده الان ومن انهيار العمله
يعني الدولار الان يقترب من 26 الى 27
ليره للدولار وهذا طبعا غير مسبوق هناك
اصلاح اقتصادي واذكر يعني نقطه اخيره يمكن
بان سبق زياره الرئيس التركي زياره ايضا
مهمه
للفريق الاقتصادي والمالي التركي الشهر
الماضي زار وزير الماليه وزير الخزانه
وحاكمه البنك المركزي التركي واجتمعوا مع
القاده في الدول الثلاثه في قطر والامارات
والسعوديه فتركيا تعول كثيرا يمكن اربعين
الى 50 مليار دولار استثمارات خليجيه تبدا
بعشر مليارات دولار نسمع عنها خلال الايام
القادمه في ختام زياره الرئيس اردوغان غدا
في ابوظبي شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور عبد الله
شايجي استاذ العلوم السياسيه في جامعه
الكويت ضيفنا من الكويت
[موسيقى]
بحث رئيس الوزراء الياباني فوميو كيشيدا
اليوم مع امير دوله قطر الشيخ تميم بن حمد
اللساني ان الطاقه وامداداتها واختتم
كيشيدا زيارته للدوحه بمؤتمر صحفي تناول
فيه علاقات بلاده مع الدول التي زارها
وقضايا الطاقه والاقتصاد والدفاع والامن
رئيس الوزراء الياباني فوميو كيشيدا اختتم
جولته الخليجيه في قطر حيث اجرى محادثات
مع امير دوله قطر الشيخ تميم بن حمد
اللساني الذي غرد على حسابي في تويتر
قائلا انه بحث مع رئيس وزراء اليابان فرص
الارتقاء بتعاون البلدين الثنائي في اطار
الشراكه الاستراتيجيه بين البلدين
الصادقين وانه جرى تبادل الاراء بشان
التطورات الاقليميه والدوليه ذات الاهتمام
المشترك لاسيما المستجدات المتعلقه بامن
الطاقه وامداداتها وفي مؤتمر صحفي في
الدوحه قال كيشيدا انه اتفق مع زعماء قطر
والسعوديه والامارات على تكثيف التعاون في
مجال الطاقه والدفاع ودعا الى تعزيز
التعاون الامني والدفاعي مع قطر والسعوديه
والامارات واشار الى ان دوله قطر تكثف
دورها على الساحه الدوليه بفضل جهودها
التوافقيه في السياسه الخارجيه وبالنسبه
لتطورات الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا قال
رئيس الوزراء الياباني ان الازمه في
اوكرانيا لن تبقى في اوروبا بل ستشكل
تحديا للعالم اجمع واعتبر ان الاعتداء على
اوكرانيا شكل نقطه تحول تاريخيه لانهاء
مرحله ما بعد الحرب البارده واوضح ان
اليابان لطالما شددت على ضروره احترام
النظام العالمي القائم وبذذ جهود خاصه في
مجالي الغذاء والطاقه وفي هذا الاطار قال
كشيده ان اليابان تعمل على تحويل الطلب
على النفط الى مصادر طاقه اخرى واستخدام
الطاقه الحديثه
الى فقرتي في المتابعه وموضوع الذكاء
الاصطناعي الذي يناقش مجلس الامن الدولي
لاول مره بشكل رسمي مخاطره على العالم
الامين العام للامم المتحده انطونيو ابدى
خلال النقاش قلقه من التفاعل بين الذكاء
الاصطناعي والاسلحه النوويه والتكنولوجيا
الحيويه
والعصبيه والروبوتات يعرف بعض الخبراء
الذكاء الاصطناعي بانه مجموعه المعلومات
والتقنيات المرتبطه بقدره نظام الحوسبه
على محاكاه العقل البشري من خلال استخدام
الخوارزميات لعرض البيانات او تصنيفها
شاهد العام الحليل طفره في تقنيات الذكاء
الاصطناعي التي باتت متاحه للعامه ومن
اشهرها تطبيق المحادثه تشات جي بي تي
وروبوت الدردشه بورد المدعومه من شركه
جوجل
والتطبيق التعليمي
يقدم الذكاء الاصطناعي قيمه مضافه لمعظم
الوظائف والاعمال والمجالات لكن دولا
ومنظمه عده تنبه من ان هذه التكنولوجيا
المذهله يمكن ان تخرج عن السيطره وتتلاعب
بالسلوك البشري لذلك تتعالى الدعوات الى
تبني لهجا العالمي في هذا الصدد واتخاذ
تدابير مشتركه للشفافيه والمساءله
والرقابه على انظمه الذكاء الاصطناعي
بريطانيا التي تتولى الرئاسه الدوريه
لمجلس الامن هذا الشهر تسعى الى القيام
بدور قياديا عالمي فيما يتعلق بضبط
استخدامات الذكاء الاصطناعي
وتستعد لندن في هذا الصدد لاستضافه قمه
حول الذكاء الاصطناعي في الخريف المقبل
على امل الخروج باتفاقيه تتضمن جمله من
الاجراءات الامنيه والوقائيه في يونيو
حزيران الماضي ايد الامين العام للامم
المتحده انطونيو اقتراحا قدمه بعض
المديرين التنفيذيين في مجال الذكاء
الاصطناعي بانشاء هيئه رقابه الدوليه
للذكاء الاصطناعي على غرار الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه ويوم الجمعه الماضي
تبنى مجلس حقوق الانسان التابع للامم
المتحده قرارا بالتوافق يدعو المجتمع
الدولي الى اتخاذ تدابير وقائيه ورقائيه
فيما يتعلق بالذكاء الاصطناعي ويدعو
القرار الى تعزيز شفافيه انظمه الذكاء
الاصطناعي وضمان ان البيانات المخصصه لهذه
التكنولوجيا يتم جمعها واستخدامها
وتشاركها وتخزينها
وحذفها بطرق تتوافق مع حقوق الانسان من
تكساس حول هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا تشاد
ميلز خبير الذكاء الاصطناعي والبرمجه
الرقميه مرحبا بك سيد تشاد ميلز هل اصبح
انشاء هذه الهيئه الرقابيه التي يتحدث
عنها غوتييرش بالمتناول هل اصبح قريبا
باعتقادك
لا اعتقد في الحقيقه اننا نعرف بكل تاكيد
اذا ما كانت سوف تشكل هناك الكثير من
الاحاديث بشان هكذا هيئه وهناك حماسه
كبيره في اوساط المتخصصين في مجال الذكاء
الاصطناعي وفي الوقت نفسه هناك مخاوف
لاننا نتحدث عن تكنولوجيا اداه جديده
يمكنها ان تستخدم للخير وللشر بعض
المشكلات التي اشرتم اليها طبعا اكدتها
الولايات الامم المتحده من مثل الانتشار
النووي والتهديدات النوويه وان تتحكم
الذكاء الاصطناعي بالعالم واراده البشر
اذا هذه تم تسطيط الضوء عليها اما بالنسبه
الى الهيئه او الوكاله هل سوف تستحدث من
غير الواضح ان روسيا تعارض بشده هذا الامر
لذلك لا نعرف ولكن بالنسبه الى الاسلحه
النوويه لا يمكننا ان نربط
الاسلحه النوويه بشكل كامل
بالذكاء الاصطناعي ولكن الذكاء الاصطناعي
لا يمكنه ان يتخذ القرارات بنيابه عن
البشر بالنسبه الى هذا الموضوع اذا يمكننا
ان نتحدث عن مجالات مختلفه على سبيل
المثال الاسلحه النوويه سيد شاهد سؤال
الذكاء الاصطناعي نحن نتحدث هنا عن هذه
الهيئه الرقبيه الدوليه التي تقترح الامم
المتحده انشاءها ولكن ماذا عن مسؤوليه
الدول بشكل فردي
كيف يمكن او هل بدا فعليا
على مستوى دولي التحدث عن هذا الموضوع
ووضع تشريعات على مستوى الدول المنفرده
لتنظيم هذا القطاع
نعم بكل تاكيد يمكننا ان نرى على مستوى
الحكومات المختلفه في العالم كل الهيئات
الحكوميه تقريبا مهتمه بالذكاء الاصطناعي
وتذهبوا بهذا الاتجاه يمكننا ان نقارن ما
يحصل بما حصل عندما اخترعت السياره في
البدايه اذا كان هناك تكنولوجيا جديده
وكان هناك مخاوف مرتبطه
باجتياز الطرق وبدات القوانين تسن للمشاه
وللسيارات اذا كله تكنولوجيا جديده تبرز
هي بحاجه الى النظم والقوانين ولكن الامر
يتطلب بعض الوقت او وقتا طويلا في بعض
الاحيان لمعرفه كل المخاطر المرتبطه
بالتكنولوجيا طبعا هناك حماسه كبيره
والجميع يعمل على هذا الامر على مستوى
المحلي ولكن ليس كل الدول ربما قادره على
مواكبه هذه الورشه الكبيره المتعلقه
بالذكاء الاصطناعي وتنظيمها واي جاد
التشريعات اللازمه لها وكل ما الى ذلك
وبالتالي الى اي مدى يزيد هذا من الهوه
بين الدول القادره على التنظيم والتعامل
مع هذه التكنولوجيا والدول غير القادره
اعتقدوا ان ما نراه بشكل عام هو انه في
المجالات التي فيها نظم اقل يكون التقدم
اكثر
الضوابط اقل تؤدي الى ابتكار اعلى اذا ما
عايننا النظم المرتبطه بالمجالات الابتكار
والتقدم عاده يحصل في مجالات غير مقيده
لربما هذه فرصه لتلك البلدان لكي تمضي
قدما طبعا انا اتابع العمل على مستوى
الهيئات الحكوميه المختلفه بالنسبه الى
الذكاء الاصطناعي ونتحدث عن مقاربات مثيره
للاهتمام
وعدد كبير من المتخصصين الذين لديهم
المعلومات الضروريه وسوف يتعين علينا ان
ننتظر
الذكاء الاصطناعي والبرمجه الرقميه ضيفنا
من تكساس
[موسيقى]
يذكرنا شريط الاخبار دوما بالصعوبات التي
يواجهها كثيرون عبر العالم وتدفعهم الى
خيارات قد تكلفهم ارواحهم تزداد الامور
ماساويه عندما يدفع الاطفال ثمن هذه
الخيارات الخبر من برشلونه تقول الشرطه
الاسبانيه ان جثه رضيعه لفظتها المياه الى
احد الشواطئ بالقرب من مدينه تركونه
المطله على البحر المتوسط الاسبوع الماضي
هي جثه ابنه طالبي لجوء لقيا حتفهما في
غرق قارب اودى بحياه جميع من على متنه
وعددهم خمسه عشر في ابريل الرضيعه لم
تتجاوز من العمر ثمانيه اشهر وحتما جاءت
الى عالمنا وغادرته دون ان تعرف حجم
التعقيدات الاجتماعيه
والاقتصاديه والسياسيه التي تدفع كثيرين
الى ترك اوطانهم وديارهم بحثا عن حياه
افضل واكثر املا قلوبنا مع المحتاجين
والماذومين عبر العالم والامل كل الامل ان
تتحسن ظروف الجميع
ختام حصاد هذه الليله مشاهدينا الكرام
اشكر لكم متابعتك